morning all boris johnson may have
vehemently denied claims that his party
whips were intimidating rebel mps but
now there is said to be growing concern
in downing street that sue grey's
investigation into parties at number 10
has uncovered damaging evidence
some of his inner circle are said to
doubt if the report will ultimately
clear him it's believed it could be
published as early as monday speaking
overnight in australia the foreign
secretary liz truss said the prime
minister has her full backing
the prime minister has my 100 support
he is doing an excellent job
britain was one of the first countries
to roll out the covert vaccine we've had
a very successful booster program we're
now able to open up our economy again in
britain and we've got one of the fastest
growing economies in the g7 and the
reason
uh that we're here in australia is
working with our very close partners
to advance freedom and democracy around
the world and to protect
our country
i want the prime minister to continue as
long as possible
in his job he is doing a fantastic job
chip there is no uh leadership election
uh very pleased to say we're once again
joined in the studio by the business
secretary quasi quartet minister lovely
to see you this morning and you you just
heard at liz truss offering uh the prime
minister her full support i i suspect i
know the answer to this one but you find
yourself in the same position 100 behind
the prime minister
what we do know are what has been
alleged since uh the minister was on the
program yesterday morning are these
these allegations of blackmail of
improper coercion uh of improper
pressure being exerted by the whips
office the prime minister hadn't had a
chance to to look at those reports
yesterday morning he will have done by
now what is the conclusion i don't know
what the conclusion is um certainly i've
been an mp for 12 years now
and i've never heard of the kind of
allegations that are being made
blackmail the idea that somehow money is
being uh withheld from communities that
need it on account of the behavior of
the mps i've never heard of anything
like that i i find it strange because
the whips office doesn't actually have
the power over spending in that way but
obviously we're going to take the
allegations seriously and we need to
look uh to the bottom of it
you know that the whips office doesn't
have responsibility for for
attributing funding i know that
the mps that will have been spoken to by
the whips office will all have been
aware of that as well isn't the the
insinuation is that the whips are
operating you know under the guidance or
at least with the tacit acceptance that
is going on of those at the top of those
in number 10. well as i said they're not
responsible and you've accepted that
they're not responsible for dispersing
actual money because i don't see how uh
they they could make those uh
allegations but i've never heard that
those uh those threats i've never heard
of that i'm just
pretty straightforward isn't it they
threatened to withhold funding as indeed
uh the former conservative mp now labour
mp for berry has suggested they've
threatened to withhold funding and the
reason that mps are reacting to those
threats is they presume that they're
coming with the approval of people more
senior than the website so
in terms of how the whipping operation
works
it's really important that the whips
actually get on with mps it's a really
important
relationship so i was very surprised to
see the allegations uh i haven't seen
any evidence uh to back them up but
obviously we have to look and see you
know what's actually gone on what what
is what would you remind us acceptable
conduct on behalf of the whips office to
what extent can they go
to try and get the castleton mps to fall
into line and do what they want
obviously in any parliamentary democracy
you've got whips who are
trying to enforce party discipline who
are talking to
mps talking to parliamentarians and
they're trying to persuade people uh to
follow
uh the government line or the party line
so that we can get legislation through
the parliament um but allegations of of
of blackmail and intimidation uh are
completely uh very unusual i've never
heard uh such allegations and i think it
would be unacceptable well how then to
account for for stories which are
appearing in the papers about those
rebels who have indicated their
intention to rebel at hannah davidson
for example a number of allegations
thrown up a number of comments you know
insinuations about her sexuality
insinuations about her relationship with
alcohol i mean are those acceptable
look i think in any uh system
political system that we have there are
lots of briefings all the time that are
being made i don't know who's making the
briefings um lots of things are said
lots of accusations about colleagues are
made but as far as the allegation the
specific allegation about whips
withholding funds i think that's
completely unacceptable i think any form
of blackmail in intimidation of that
kind uh is simply has no place
in british politics
i don't think i don't think uh it's it's
it's it's something that i've ever heard
of i don't think that this is happening
but it's certainly incredibly serious
i'll ask the question again i mean what
what what would happen what should
happen actually in your view if these
allegations are substantiated look i
don't want to get drawn into what will
happen if unsubstantiated allegations
have proven true all i would like to say
is that uh it's completely unacceptable
and we need to get to the bottom of the
matter but i find it unlikely uh frankly
given the nature what i know of the
whips given what i know of how the
parliament works uh today i'd find it
very unlikely that these allegations are
true
let's talk briefly then about about sue
gray and there are a number of reports
this morning suggesting that she has
uncovered an email warning martin
reynolds to cancel the party if that is
confirmed the prime minister has to go
doesn't he no i don't think uh that's
the case at all again we're pre-judging
i know people want to um come to
conclusions uh before
we we can do so we've got to see what
sue gray says and then once the report
is out uh we can draw our own
conclusions as the prime minister has
consistently said the prime minister's
also said a number of things which seem
to run counter to the idea that there
was indeed a warning that this party
should not go ahead because it was a
party i mean he has said that he
received no warning i mean if if he is
shown to have either misled the house or
indeed lied as steve baker has said he
has to go doesn't he so
as i said before
i think we've got to wait to the report
let's see what sue grey says and then
after that i'm sure the prime minister
will make a statement
why do you have to wait for the report
to answer a question as straightforward
as if the prime minister has misled the
house or the prime minister has lied he
has to go what why is it that an
impossible constant answer right now the
answer is obvious isn't it consistently
we've said consistently
that we will wait uh for sue gray's
report i know you're trying to ask me
hypothetical questions if this happens
and if that happens uh should the prime
minister say
it's a binary answer does the prime
minister have to resign if he's proved
to have mislead the house i mean in
other times
you wouldn't have i wouldn't have had to
push you for an answer so all i all i
want to say is in this specific instance
we have a report uh and i want to see
the report before we make any further uh
uh further statements
i mean i mean one of the one of the
accusations that has been made of
christian wakeford is that he has been
some in some manner attention seeking by
alleging that not just was funding for a
school in his constituency threatened to
be withheld but also there was some
suggestions that boundary changes could
be made that would be detrimental to his
continuing success as a as a politician
i mean the person who accused him of
attention seeking was you know one
nadine doris who appeared and i'm a
celebrity for goodness sakes i don't
know about what his motivations were i
think you'd have to ask christian why he
defected or why he essentially uh
changed uh uh you know turned coats and
changed his political allegiance that's
a matter for him i don't know what his
motivations uh were um and as you will
appreciate he's a labour mp now and of
course you know his job part of his job
is to try and uh discredit the
government i fully accept that but you'd
have to ask him as to why he he defected
i i wonder if we can just turn just
briefly onto on to covet um and of
course there are there have been a
number of changes that have been
announced in a number of changes that
will take place over the next few weeks
specifically on the issue of
masquerading in schools
we are seeing a number of reports now
that despite the
the direction from central government
there will be a number of schools still
insisting on children wearing masks in
environments which the prime minister
says they don't have to anymore what
what should happen in those schools what
should the parents of those children do
i think that they should um
follow official guidance now how the
schools
run as far as i'm concerned um you know
that's a matter also for teachers and
parents to negotiate but the guidance
from the prime minister is very clear
that we won't need to be wearing masks
so just to be very specific on this
point
schools which are telling their pupils
that they should continue to wear masks
they are wrong
uh i all i say is that they have to uh
follow the guidance but i'm not going to
be i'm not here what happens if they
don't i'm not here as a business
secretary i understand i'm not here as
the business secretary responsible for
the economy which i thought we might be
talking about
to enforce uh to tell uh school teachers
and head teachers how they're gonna run
run schools that's i'm afraid not my
remit
okay one one thing which will be your
remit is encouraging civil servants
working at your department absolutely
come back and be back at their desk when
will we be back to normal levels i'm
hopeful that we can do this as quickly
as possible we're talking to our work
style particularly in phase in my
department
and i've said that people should start
getting back to normal as soon as they
can
the hospitality industry though calling
for a return to emergency outdoor dining
rooms on the high street i mean we
understand that there may be another a
few other measures being looked at at
the moment perhaps an extension
more grant money perhaps extension on
tax relief but what is your
understanding is there going to be
anything more for the hospitality
industry i think we've provided very
liberally for the sector over the last
two years the chance has been extremely
generous with furlough schemes they've
had a business rates uh holiday many uh
businesses they've also had a vat
holiday as well so there's been huge
support something like 400 billion
pounds over the last uh uh 18 months or
so has been put into the economy and
obviously i speak to hospitality leaders
all the time and i'm suggesting that uh
you know what has been the great success
is the vaccine rollout that's managed to
keep the economy going and all the
hospitality leaders the the ceos the
people who run these companies have said
the one thing that will destroy the
hospitality sector is a return to
lockdown we've avoided that through the
vaccine rollout we've got one of the
most open economies in the world at the
moment and also we're seeing a very fast
growth rate so all of that's incredibly
encouraging and i think hospitality
leaders people in the sector are very
happy that we've avoided uh the
lockdowns well that was close enough to
an answer that i am going to move
straight on to your brief adventure and
you can explain to me what a gigafactory
might be it's going to be something
which is going to be very important to
our economy moving forward
some will be wondering why perhaps
government funds were necessary to for
its construction so the reason why there
has been some government money put into
this is that we're in a global race
every advanced manufacturing country in
the world wants to attract people to
build as you say these gigafactories and
what the gigafactory is is simply a
manufacturing facility for batteries
and batteries power electric vehicles
and
people know that electric vehicles are
the new coming
form of transport people are
transforming their lives by buying these
things and they're running essentially
on electricity this is something that's
happening all over the world and clearly
manufacturing countries like ourselves
like germany france others
want to be able to manufacture
batteries for electric vehicles because
they can see the demand for them and the
announcement we made uh yesterday i was
up in uh blithe near newcastle uh it's
hugely significant i mean it creates
something like 3 000 immediate jobs on
the site and then 5 000 jobs locally an
extra 5 000 jobs for what we call the
supply chain the companies that make the
materials that feed into the factory so
why then the needs for you know i mean
reports vary but it seems to be a figure
of around about 100 million pounds worth
of government money is being put into
this so we put in then the need we put
in 10 million tens of millions the
actual amount of money that's being
invested is uh more than north of 2.5
billion pounds so there's a huge
leverage in terms of for every pound
we're putting in we're getting 25 pounds
of private investment and as i said the
reason why we've put a little bit of
government money into this is that this
is a global competition every other
country advanced manufacturing country
is giving subsidies is giving breaks uh
to uh uh companies to invest in electric
vehicle manufacturing and this is a once
in a generation opportunity if you
haven't got any ability to make electric
vehicles uh th that you you're never
going to build that and you've got one
opportunity uh to do that in the early
2020s quite a quiet always good to see
you thanks very much thank you very good
to see you thanks neil
still to come on the program this
morning can boris johnson survive as
prime minister i will just heard from
the minister at half past seven i'll be
discussing that with jack blanchard from
politico and raw patton from the critic
magazine
and at 10 2 the first minister of wales
mark drakeford will be talking about the
easing of covert restrictions in that
country
also this morning the art academy that's
helping people with their mental health
well within the past few minutes we have
had the latest retail figures covering
the christmas period our business
correspondent paul kelso has been taking
a look at the numbers uh paul good to
see this morning well certainly i know
that for me christmas was an expensive
one this year what for the nation as a
whole
yeah these december retail figures this
is where we find out whether everyone
has been girls and boys and just how
generous santa was i'm afraid the news
is not good retail sales in december
were down 3.7
they have recovered to above uh
pre-covered levels of shopping on the
high street and elsewhere but across all
sectors
food and non-food crucially the
gift-giving that drives so much of
spending in december sales were down and
they're also down on last christmas
nearly one percent down on december
2020. now there's not a huge amount of
detail as to why this might be in the
office for national statistics release
but what there is points towards omicron
of course we had the uh imposition of
plan b uh midway through december but
the squeeze on uh consumer behavior
really from omicron began right at the
beginning christmas spending uh spree or
what the retailers hope would be on
black friday was when we first heard
about it and
shopping centers have reported being at
their quietest since july 2021 and
retailers at the ons have spoken to have
all said they felt omicron was a reason
that people were staying at home there
was an increase in online sales perhaps
unsurprisingly up to nearly 30 percent
that's up three or four percent on
november so the online retail boom
hastened by covid that certainly seems
to be here to stay but i think what will
be worrying uh certainly to retailers as
they look ahead is if people weren't
willing to spend
christmas or even at the same levels as
a year ago of course when we stick we
had a previous wave of coved how on
earth are people going to be thinking
about their what expendable income
they've got as we go into the new year
with all the cost pressures that we've
been talking about quite frequently
energy prices tax increases interest
rates going up this inflationary
environment in the economy there was not
it appears a christmas dividend for
retailers
paul many thanks indeed
now the foreign secretary liz truss has
warned moscow to step back from a
possible war in ukraine speaking in
australia she condemned what she called
russia's increased aggression
the kremlin haven't learnt the lessons
of history
they dream of recreating the soviet
union
or a kind of greater russia
carving up territory based on ethnicity
and language
they claim they want stability
while they work to threaten and
destabilize others
we know what lies down that path
and the terrible toll in lives lost in
human suffering it brings
that's why we urge president putin to
desist and step back from ukraine
before he makes a massive strategic
mistake
let's speak to our international affairs
editor dominic wagon who is in geneva
where the u.s secretary of state will be
meeting his russian counterpart for
crucial talks at later today uh good to
see you this morning dominic just in
terms of what we might expect from these
talks and what everyone wants is a
de-escalation of the tensions but it
doesn't quite feel it at that point yet
no we're looking at an hour and a half
of talks this morning which isn't that
long is it neil and for the americans
the challenge is to bring their
characters stick approach and hope it
works this time because last week's week
of talks
failed to bring about any breakthrough
the carrots are american compromises if
there are any concessions towards what
they have described as the outlandish
demands the russians have been making so
is there any way the americans have
moved towards these demands that the
russians have been making and the
russians want to see their responses
in a written form that serga lavrov can
take back to moscow with him the stick
is the threat of swift severe sanctions
that we've heard their diplomats
threatening for some time should
vladimir putin invade russia and in that
challenge
blinking was undermined by his
president's words of course a couple of
nights ago where joe biden said that the
response to a russian division would
depend on what kind of invasion if it
was a full-scale invasion yet massive
severe consequences if it was a minor
incursion then you could see the allies
ending up fighting over what to do about
it so sergey lavrov's challenge you
might think is to find that gap those
gaps those weaknesses and divisions in
the allied ranks and drive a wedge
between them in the talks today he's
also got to convince the americans that
the russians are serious when they
threaten what putin has called military
technical responses
if he doesn't get his way i think at the
end of this we'll get a better idea as
to whether the russians feel there's
anything worth talking about lavrov will
take those demands or those responses
back to moscow and then it'll be up to
his leader
vladimir putin to work out what to do
next does he feel that there is
something worth continuing talking about
despite the failures we've seen to bring
about any breakthrough in these talks so
far or does he feel it's something it's
time now to do something more drastic
dom many thanks
uh some other news now and covid rules
are being relaxed in parts of the uk
today
the first minister of wales mark
drakeford is to announce an easing of
restrictions moving the country to alert
level zero now this allows crowds at
outdoor sporting events and
unrestricted outdoor hospitality
covered restrictions will also be eased
in northern ireland from today where the
rule of six in pubs and bars will be
removed as well as the limit on
gatherings of no more than three
households
and as for the most up-to-date covert
figures in the uk 107
364 new cases reported
330 new deaths bringing the total number
of people who've died within 28 days of
a positive tests to 153
2202
austria's parliament has approved a
universal covert 19 vaccine mandate for
adults that's the first of its kind in
europe the mandate will come into force
next month with authorities writing to
every household to inform them of the
new rules
from mid-march police will start
checking people's vaccination status
during routine checks
thousands of pensioners have been
waiting decades for repayment of their
pensions worth over a billion pounds and
according to the public accounts
committee the department for working
pensions is accused of short-changing
130 000 people since 1985.
meg hillier chair of the public accounts
committee spoke to us yesterday
behind the scenes the dwp has a complex
set of i.t systems which all have don't
talk to each other so it requires a
highly trained member of staff to
understand what questions to interrogate
different systems on match that all
together and work out if someone's being
paid the right pension and that's where
the problem has arisen because these
systems are not connected
an american airlines flight to london
was forced to return to miami after a
passenger refused to wear a face mask
the airline called miami police and
officers escorted a woman from the plane
now a 57 year old tongan man who was
forced to swim for 28 hours after being
swept out to sea by the tsunami has been
described as a real life aquaman lasalle
of falau tried to climb a tree to escape
the water but was swept away by the
torrent greg milam reports now from fiji
lizala falau never expected to be
sitting in front of the cameras but
that's what a remarkable story of
survival does for you the 57 year old a
retired carpenter who finds even walking
difficult survived in the water for 28
hours after being washed out to sea he
ended up eight miles from home and told
us his faith got him through
the most scariest part
to me during the ordeal was
when the waves took me from land into
the sea
what came into my mind when i was
helpless
were two things
one
that i still had faith in god
two
is my family and i i only remembered
what uh
how my family would think
at that moment
maybe
he died
much of his home island of a tata was
destroyed by the tsunami that hit tonga
still his hope is to go back
everything is gone
but my heart
is and i was raised there my parents are
raised are buried there
and i will go back there one day
inspiring stories are one thing the
practical needs are urgent the arrival
then of the first aid flights packed
with water shelter generators and
communications equipment was a welcome
sight in tonga on the runway locals
spent days clearing a volcanic ash by
hand
the protective gear evidence of the
effort to make sure they don't bring
covet as well
lizala falau now has the nickname
aquaman after a movie he says he's never
seen the real life experiences of nature
he says aplenty
no man can withstand the power of nature
what we need to understand is
how we react
when it comes
how do we treat it when it comes for me
i just want to be cool
to be calm
when it comes
he seems to have succeeded greg milam
sky news fiji
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure will keep things mostly
settled but the cloud will increase from
the northwest limiting any frost this
weekend it's a mostly fine start with a
widespread frost locally severe in the
south but the northwest is cloudier and
milder there'll be plenty of morning
sunshine for eastern scotland central
southern and eastern england and the far
south of ireland elsewhere the cloud
will build giving some patchy drizzle in
places mainly on the hills in northwest
scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways a
reminder as to our top stories this are
covered restrictions are being relaxed
in wales with no limits on the number of
people who can meet outdoors
the foreign secretary has told russia to
step back from ukraine
warning that an invasion would lead to a
terrible quagmire and loss of life is
similar to that during the soviet afghan
war
[Music]
sky news understands that downing street
is nervous but the lockdown party
investigation could contain damaging
evidence which might bring down the
prime minister
now within the last half an hour the
business secretary kwazii kwarteng has
told the party line saying that we need
to wait for the results of the
pseudo-grey investigation on accusations
though that rebel tory mps have been
facing intimidation and blackmail
threats from government whips he said he
didn't think it was likely but the
claims would be investigated
as far as the allegation the specific
allegation about whips withholding funds
i think that's completely unacceptable i
think any form of blackmail and
intimidation of that kind uh is simply
has no place
in british politics
i don't think i don't think uh it's it's
it's it's something that i've ever heard
of i don't think that this is happening
but it's certainly incredibly serious
i'll ask the question again i mean what
what what would happen what should
happen actually in your view if these
allegations are substantiated look i
don't want to get drawn into what will
happen if unsubstantiated allegations
have proven true all i would like to say
is that it's completely unacceptable and
we need to get to the bottom of the
matter but i find it unlikely uh frankly
let's bring in our political
correspondent kate mccann uh morning
kate well i had a goal um but how close
did we actually get to an answer there
on the very specific questions of those
those allegations being made about the
way in which the whips office and indeed
others within government are operating
right now yeah i think look at the end
of the day you could have asked him that
question 15 times over and you wouldn't
necessarily have got any further with it
because at the moment everybody in
government is waiting for that sugree
report and until that comes out they're
just not prepared to go anywhere near
any of these questions despite how
serious actually some of them are and i
thought it was really telling when you
said you know not just these allegations
about money potentially being withheld
or withdrawn or mps being threatened
with things by the whips but the
allegations of stories in the newspapers
around some of these potential rebels or
people who've expressed you know concern
about the way number 10 is run and the
fact that quasi quatang said well you
know this goes on in politics all the
time that's not really necessarily for
those people who are facing it a good
enough answer and there are questions
about the culture and the way that
politics is running at the minute and
actually that feeds into doesn't it that
conversation in number 10 about why were
parties acceptable why did people think
that it was okay to bend the rules or
even break the rules in some
circumstances so sue gray is the next
big pinch point i think for the prime
minister and when we talk about letters
and the potential for that to be
problematic that's when it really comes
back into focus i think you might just
have a point okay many thanks indeed
so the big question is obviously can
boris johnson survive as prime minister
uh joining us this morning to discuss
that jack blanchard uk political editor
at political europe and rob hutton
parliamentary sketch writer at the
critic magazine chaps very good to see
you both um rob let's let's come to you
first and just the broad brush question
to get us started here is this survival
for the prime minister certainly senior
figures within his cabinet might not
wish it to be the case but they're
certainly saying it's the case
i think it's not
it's a it's a scandal the public has
noticed you can get away with an awful
lot in politics
if the public doesn't notice and boris
johnson has got away with an awful lot
things public noticed things public
didn't mind this is something the public
does mind and has definitely noticed and
whatever happens i actually can't see
what sue gray can bring back
that would say
you know what it was completely fine to
go out even even just to that single may
20th party even if there were nothing
else
it was okay to have that it was okay for
you to go out there i i i mean
maybe she's going to reveal he was
working undercover to bust party
organizers or something but i mean what
what's she going to say
um jack what do you make of the kind of
the the latest revelations in this story
the idea that the whips office have been
deploying you know underhand tactics
threatening to withhold funding looking
at the
constituency boundaries i mean the
argument from some senior politicians
appears to be well this has gone on
since time immemorial but in what other
profession would it be appropriate to
threaten to coerce action in quite that
manner
well the answer is almost no other
profession but then politics is like no
other profession and the truth is that
this sort of thing has gone on pretty
much forever since we had politicians
you know the skull duggary and the
arm-twisting and so on to get them to
each other to do what they want them to
do is just how politics works and people
might not like it but that is the
reality of it um so having said that if
they're really prepared to start
revealing text messages and secret voice
recordings as is suggested in some of
the newspapers this morning about some
of the actions of the whips that really
could shine a light on practices which
have been very much done behind the
curtain uh since time immemorial and i
think that would really change the
picture completely in westminster that
might actually start to change the
culture but it'll be a pretty nuclear
option for for an mp to do um it's hard
to see any way back from within their
party if they're really prepared to do
that
rob
shortly after the crossing of the floor
of christian wakeford there was well
there emerged two schools of thought uh
one that this was incredibly damaging
for the prime minister and would hasten
his exit the other view that this
actually served to sharpen minds in the
conservative back benches some letters
made with withdrawn and a few others may
well have decided not to submit it both
can't be true so which one is it
i think both can be true actually um
losing a backbencher losing an mp is
clearly bad
okay and any any pretence that this is a
blessing in disguise it's like would you
like to lose another one
uh obviously that's obviously it's bad
on the other hand it does also seem to
be the case that it did
slightly
sort of sharpen minds is the wrong thing
because i think everyone's pretty acute
on this but that it did slightly just
give give tory mps pause because if
you're planning to defenestrate the
prime minister your argument is i am
doing this for the good of the party
uh
and if if
if you don't want it to be associated
with a guy who no longer wants the good
of the party who's gone and joined
another party so
i i sort of
yes i mean i i i think i think it sort
of it it helped him for a couple of days
but the idea that
the idea that in a month's time everyone
will be saying oh yeah you know what you
know what really turned things around
for boris johnson when his mps started
leaving are you
again i mean no obviously not
i mean jack so is there then in your
mind um just having listened to robin is
there an inevitability that that we will
get to the requisite number of letters
to trigger that confidence forward
and if so
from that point onwards i mean there
still remains a chance that the prime
minister can win it
yeah every chance i mean you know even
theresa may won a confidence vote from
her own party um you know and she she
was not the most popular or effective
prime minister as many people remember
having said that she won the confidence
vote and of course was still turfed out
by her party not very many months after
that so even winning a confidence vote
uh for boris johnson would certainly not
be the end of the matter having said
that i am less certain than rob about
the uh the ultimate outcome about all of
this simply because this is boris
johnson we're talking about and this is
a guy who's been getting away with it
for the whole of his life
and i certainly don't think it's beyond
him to squeak his way out of this latest
scrape either that's certainly what they
believe is going to happen in downing
street i think the hope is that the
report by sue gray will be pretty
inconclusive in terms of whether rules
were actually broken and
gray areas if i can use the uh slightly
unfortunate pun around uh working you
can use it once you can use it once jack
never again
i promise i promise i won't get there
again but that might allow the prime
minister to say look yes maybe this
wasn't quite the most appropriate thing
but you know there's been no evidence
found rule breaking let's all move on
and here's lots of shiny things i want
to announce now to talk about instead
and uh his supporters in the newspapers
will try and move the story on at that
point and it is possible that they will
succeed i don't think it's certain or
even necessarily that likely but i
certainly wouldn't be putting my money
on boris johnson being out anytime soon
i mean rob the the the insinuation from
some of the prime minister's closest
allies is that all of this focus on
parties which took place months ago on
on frippery and froth on on westminster
bubble stories it's perhaps distracting
attention from the fact you know we've
got the russians massing on the border
with ukraine i mean there is a degree of
truth to that argument isn't that there
is a degree of focus that has perhaps
been taken away from something perhaps
rather more newsworthy yeah that okay
i'll i'll i'll give you the russians
of ukraine as a as a bigger and
potentially more important story
the thing is though saying oh well it's
about a glass of wine is not right it's
it's about
integrity fundamentally it's about do
the people who set the rules follow the
rules
and
when the prime minister stands up and
says
that didn't happen and says to
parliament that never happened
do we believe him and i thought what was
interesting yesterday was that when
boris johnson said well i've never heard
of any whips threatening anyone
the the immediate thought that everyone
went to is that well you know six weeks
ago you were telling us that you'd never
heard about any parties you know
happening outside your office underneath
your flat
once you lose trust
with the public on something as i said i
mean this is where i differ with jay
because because he has got away with
lots of stuff but he's got away lots of
stuff that fundamentally people thought
didn't matter
and everybody noticed lockdown and
everybody understood the rules of
lockdown and
um
and even you know if you weren't if even
if you didn't have a tragic story
everybody knows what they were supposed
to be doing
in 2020 and
to have the prime minister stand up and
say god you know i saw all these people
and i just didn't it never occurred to
me that that was a problem you know
between press conferences in which i've
been telling people you can meet one
person if you stand two meters away and
you keep moving you know but you mustn't
have too much
it yeah
yeah you know so so but yeah but it's
easy to easy are there other really
worrying things going on in the world
yes there are yes yeah
hannah thanks very much indeed now
coveted restrictions in wales are due to
be relaxed from today with no limits to
the number of people who can take part
in outdoor events joining us once again
on the programme the first minister of
wales mark drakeford mr drakeford good
to see you this morning
just explain that the level of
confidence that you must be possessed of
uh to be pushing forward the rolling
back of these covered measures
well neil if i was summarizing the
position in wales i would say that we
are over the worst uh but not out of the
woods
this week the numbers have improved day
by day we've now got the lowest number
of people suffering from coronavirus
of any part of the united kingdom and
numbers in hospital have started to come
down as well
but we've still got to monitor the data
day by day make sure that it is safe to
take the next step today as you said all
restrictions in outdoor activities are
returning to what we call alert level
zero
and provided things remain on track on
friday of next week
we'll be able to do the same thing for
indoor activities as well
just in terms of of events and of course
with the six nations fast uh fast
approaching with plenty of people where
you are very much looking forward to
being able to watch one of the games you
know in the stadium surrounded by the
rest of their fans
what the
of of those indoor events for which for
the time being at least the covered pass
will still be required
for entry i mean is that something that
you see continuing in perpetuity
uh not in perpetuity uh i certainly hope
that
uh we're committed to reviewing that on
the 10th of february
so that will stay in place uh for a bit
longer than some of the other
protections we put in place in order to
make sure
that wales goes on having a smooth path
out of the omicron wave that hit us so
very badly over christmas and early in
the new year
but which in line with the modeling uh
seems to be receding very quickly as
well
well just on that point just for just
for clarity then as you say the next
three weekly review due to take place on
on the 10th of february i think you said
is it possible that that is the day on
which
you could conceivably see an end to
using the covet pass for entry into
indoor
events i think it's conceivable but by
no means guaranteed you know we've just
seen in the last week or so how fast
things can change uh with this virus on
the 10th of february is still three
weeks away so uh if things continue to
improve at their current rate and we
were in a position to lift some of the
further protections of course that's
what we wanted to do
but in wales we will only do it when
we're sure we have the clinical advice
the scientific advice that would tell us
that it would be safe to do that
can you just explain though just a bit
of the justification for the covet pass
itself as i understand it a big brother
watch the campaign organization uh
seeking a judicial review of the
mandatory covert pass policy
uh yes that is certainly the case and
other governments
face similar challenges
we are confident that the covid pass has
done two things
it has offered extra protections to
people from falling ill because you know
that if you're in a venue where
everybody else has been fully vaccinated
then you know that those risks of
catching coronavirus are reduced
and it's given people confidence to
return to those settings
as well
knowing that if you do go to somewhere
where the pass is mandatory then
everybody else there has done the right
thing has taken up vaccination has done
what they can to protect themselves
and i've been really struck by the
number of people who've said to me
that the past makes them feel far more
confident in going out going about
taking part in those sorts of uh
settings so it's been good for health
but it's been good for business as well
how confident then are you that the the
actions being taken in terms of the
rollback of at covert restrictions just
over the border from wales in england
how confident to you that the pace of
that change here is not perhaps just
slightly too quick given where the data
is
well
certainly we would not be moving at the
pace that english ministers have been
announcing look i'd have to say uh
anybody watching what has gone on in
westminster will know
that those announcements are not driven
by the science they're not part of a
carefully thought out plan they're just
an effort by uk ministers to find a
different headline from the one that has
dominated the news because of all the
difficulties that they have got into of
their own making
now here in wales we are in a better
position than that uh our government is
able to go on making
sensible cautious planned decisions
rooted in the science and in keeping
people in will safe and i think the
contrast between our two positions has
been pretty stark this week
let's focus then just briefly if we can
of the travails of the prime minister
indeed the conservative government in
general
do you think there is an inevitability
now that that leadership challenge will
come to fruition do you think boris
johnson's position
is in doubt
well you know conservative mps have been
fighting each other like ferrets in a
sack uh this week and it's very hard to
see how the prime minister survives and
even if he were to survive uh he will
just limp on
because he's never going to escape the
damage that this week has done to his
reputation uh from my point of view the
thing that worries me the most is the
fact that you know the uk government is
frozen
uh by the impact of what has happened
to them uh they're just not able to make
the sorts of decisions you'd expect a
government to make because everything is
seen through this lens
the attempt to try and shore up the
prime minister
to protect him from the attacks that his
own side are making on him and that
means it's a government that's turned in
on itself
and isn't capable of doing the job that
it was elected to do
mark drakeford i'm afraid we will have
to leave it there thank you so much for
joining us again on the program
appreciate it